we all know Ghostbusters is the greatest
movie of all time but here's 18 facts
about Ghostbusters you probably don't
know you never studied according to
legend a trailer was released with a
real 1-800 number
leading to a recorded message from Bill
Murray and Dan Aykroyd the number
supposedly got a thousand calls per hour
24 hours a day for six weeks alternate
casting choices included Eddie Murphy as
Winston Michael Keaton as Egon and John
Belushi as Venkman
but after Belushi's death dan Aykroyd
used him as the inspiration for Slimer
John Candy was originally cast in the
role of Lois and the role of gozer was
originally supposed to be played by Paul
Reubens in the original script the
Ghostbusters were city workers like
firemen they wore blue jumpsuits helmets
with visors and used magic wands most of
the movies best lines are improvised
including you're more like a game show
host someone ask you if you know
adhesive here just good old-fashioned
saliva the firehouse exterior is in New
York while the interior is in LA my
uncle thought he was st. jerome st.
jerome is the patron saint of librarians
these alternate takes reveal different
original names for the movie this is
what 50 gallons of shaving cream looks
like cameo by porn star ron jeremy film
debut of Larry King this is a practical
effect Sigourney Weaver wore a full body
cast and was strapped to a post hidden
in the curtains the term proton pack is
never said until halfway through
ghostbusters to the voice of Zul is
director ivan reitman and finally the
odds of winning the jackpot on the
official Ghostbusters slot machine are
only slightly higher than the odds of
Bill Murray appearing in ghostbusters 3
so be good